François Patriat votre réaction à cette
intervention d'Emmanuel Macron il assume
il en douce la réforme malgré son
impopularité lucide courageux combatif
un président qui assume parce qu'il
prend un texte difficile à entendre bien
qui assume qui assume la popularité qui
dit je le fais parce que c'est pour les
générations futures c'est pour l'avenir
de ce pays je le fais au détriment des
critiques aujourd'hui je trouvais que ce
président était à la fois Judit lucide
courageux et combatif trois dans ces
bottes Patrick canard Emmanuel Macron
quel est votre réaction alors que l'on
entend déjà à gauche certains qui
dénoncent mensonges déni mépris Laurent
Berger Philippe Martinez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon arrogance suffisance
condescendance et irresponsabilité
devant les Français moi je suis sidéré
parce que j'ai entendu intérêt en
pensant en français qui aujourd'hui one
pénalisés par un président qui ne les
comprend pas d'ailleurs en fait le
Président nous a dit mais j'ai un regret
c'est que les Français n'ont pas compris
ma réforme
ça réforme qu'il s'agit le problème
c'est que nous avons un président qui ne
comprend plus les Français et ça c'est
bien plus grave votre réaction Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne est-ce que bien le
gouvernement est conforté car la réforme
est adoptée ou affaibli car la réforme
reste très contestée et est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron par rapport à la
situation de crise dans laquelle nous
sommes à une réponse pour vous
suffisante non c'est pour moi une
intervention qui est extrêmement
décevante d'abord parce que très confuse
parce que de nouveau faire une liste de
15 20 chantiers de nouveau à ouvrir ou à
réouvrir parce que si je me suis posé la
question en l'écoutant pourquoi n'a-t-il
pas fait cette intervention 7 mois plus
tôt pourquoi il y a 7 mois de cela n'a
pas pris le soin effectivement d'abord
peut-être de mettre en oeuvre et en
place porter au Parlement une loi sur le
plan emploi sur le travail puisque là il
la réclame mais il fallait d'abord
commencer par cette loi sur le travail
et ensuite éventuellement en venir à la
loi sur la réforme des retraites donc
tout est à l'envers et je crois
aujourd'hui que les Français peuvent
être extrêmement déçus parce que ce
qu'attendait les Français aussi dans
cette période de crise particulièrement
grave que traverse notre pays une crise
politique une crise démocratique et une
crise sociale c'est de la Concorde c'est
de la compréhension c'est de la
bienveillance c'est de la confiance et
je n'ai pas trouvé tout cela au
rendez-vous pas convaincu par le chef de
l'État qui pourtant a saluer la droite
républicaine celle qui a voté la réforme
des retraites oui mais la droite
républicaine a toujours été cohérente et
responsable nous avons une ligne qui a
toujours été claire cette ligne on ne
veut pas en changer et nous avons
toujours porté dans l'ADN de notre
famille politique le travailler plus et
la valeur travail il n'y avait aucune
raison que nous ne fassions pas en sorte
que ce projet de réforme des retraites
soit voté qu'on aille jusqu'au bout du
texte au Sénat et que nous puissions
aussi l'enrichir à travers les
amendements que nous avons porté votre
réaction Mélanie vosge à cette
intervention du président de la
République qui je le répète et bien
estime que c'est une réforme qui est
faite pour l'intérêt général du pays
malgré son impopularité moi je crois
qu'on a vu un président de la République
aujourd'hui dont le mépris et
l'arrogance qu'il a pour les Français
non des guêpes visiblement que l'amour
et la fierté qu'il a pour lui-même il
nous raconte que il choisit l'intérêt
général plutôt que la popularité moi je
crois que c'est exactement l'inverse il
a quand même traité aujourd'hui 80% des
Français de factieux il a comparé des
manifestations pacifistes qui ont
vocation à faire respecter la volonté de
la nation et aussi du Parlement à la
prise d'assaut du Capitole et au fond je
crois que c'est l'inverse qu'il fait
c'est pas protéger l'intérêt général
malgré l'impopularité de la réforme
c'est mettre en danger l'intérêt général
on est au bord du précipice il nous
propose d'y plonger je crois que c'est
au contraire totalement irresponsable et
très dangereux pour ce qui va se passer
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent alors vous le dites le
président de la République a parlé des
manifestations de l'opposition qu'il y a
dans la rue et là aussi donné le
contexte d'une phrase très polémique
c'est dernière heure le fait qu'il avait
dit que la foule n'avait pas de
légitimité face au peuple qui s'exprime
à travers les élus lui a expliqué qu'il
parlait alors des violences on l'écoute
tout à l'heure lors de cette interview
quand des groupes utilisent l'extrême
violence pour agresser des élus de la
République qu'il soit parlementaire
aujourd'hui ou même
malheureusement chaque semaine quand ils
utilisent la violence sans règles
absolues parce qu'ils ne sont pas
contents de quelque chose alors là ça
n'est plus la République la démocratie
je vous le distrer nettement il faut
dire on respecte on écoute on essaie
d'avancer pour le pays et je vais y
revenir parce que je compare au fond de
cette réforme mais on ne peut accepter
ni les faction ni les factions et je
vous donne aussi la réaction d'Olivier
Faure en question
de la République met encore plus
d'explosifs sur un petit peu les braises
actuelles ça n'est pas susceptible
d'apaiser la situation Patrick canard
cette république
est aujourd'hui
pas au centre de l'Union des Français il
est en train de devenir un apprenti
sorcier
pompier pyromane au choix voir un
mélange des deux enfermé dans un bunker
son bunker non pas le bunker Jupiter à
l'Élysée mais le bunker de certitude et
de suffisance qui est qui est le sien
moi je suis très inquiet d'une telle
déconnexion avec des propos de
provocation le mot de factieux
si les Français qui vont défiler demain
par million sont des factieux ça veut
dire que notre démocratie est en danger
je pense que ce qu'on appelait les
manifestations spontanées non autorisées
il y en a eu qui 1200 depuis jeudi
dernier oui je vais vous donner la clé
favorable à la violence à aucune
violence à aucune provocation de la part
d'une extrême gauche
quand on connaît bien et que j'ai que
j'ai combattu dans toute ma vie
politique je dis simplement que quand un
président de la République d'ailleurs de
le aujourd'hui refuse de recevoir
l'Inter syndicale qui lui a demandé il y
a dix jours monsieur le Président il y a
un problème dans ce pays on a envie de
parler avec vous recevez-nous j'ai la
lettre sous les jeux de réponse c'est un
déni un déni de responsabilité et
maintenant il dit mais finalement je
suis le responsable qui porte cette
réforme et je vais vous l'imposer on
marche à l'envers madame Estrosi ça
sonne a évoqué à juste titre le fait
qu'on aurait dû avoir une loi travail
avant la loi sur les retraites
aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un masse
Trump d'incohérences de la part du du
président de la République et je pense
que que les Français doivent être
absolument abasourdi par autant de j'ai
envie de dire de contre vérité par
rapport à ce qu'ils vivent comment un
président peut-il être aussi déconnecté
y compris en essayant de faire du
débauchage de l'âme saunage auprès de
tel ou tel parlementaire pour avoir des
majorités
à la droite notamment François Patriat
votre
d'évidence et bien certains estiment à
gauche et bien qu'il n'est pas du tout
parvenu à apaiser alors qu'on voit une
radicalisation de la mobilisation alors
que on voit effectivement beaucoup de
désordre et de violence dans les rues je
crois qu'au-delà des propos j'ai tenu
tout à l'heure sur l'engagement du
président il y a aussi une forme
d'empotite d'empathie de propositions
qui respectait aujourd'hui l'attitude
des syndicales attitude de la droite au
Sénat l'attitude de ceux qui dans ce
débat ont gardé une forme de dignité et
non pas appeler à l'insurrection on a
dans ce pays on a une gauche faxieuse
une partie de la droite d'un Anastasie
qui est lâche on a eu les médias qui ont
fait tout pour se pourrir ce débat et
puis un corps pathétique bon face à tout
cela c'est vrai que on le voit sur ce
tableau aujourd'hui je suis tout seul
contre trois avec des gens mais je crois
que je voudrais dire à Monsieur kaner
alors
la méthode ça pose problème
nous avons pour habitude de plus dans ce
pays de dépenser plus et de ne plus
produire nous appartenez aujourd'hui à
cette catégorie des lieux politiques qui
continue à dire qu'il faut dépenser plus
tous les jours qu'il faut travailler
moins tous les jours qu'il ne faut plus
produire ce qui conduit la France et la
déchéance
je vous conseille que le président des
très riches et là avec vous vous le
souhaitez et il est très riche peuvent
dormir tranquille dans ce pays quand
aujourd'hui on a fait ce que vous n'avez
jamais fait ce que nous n'avons jamais
fait de moi de monter à ce point les
minima sociaux de crédits pour permettre
que le travail paye mieux de faire
régresser le chômage on a de leçons à
donner à personne
qui vont demander de l'argent qui font
l'aumône qui se prostitue nous leur
dites quoi ces étudiants mais vous qui
avez été ministre de la Jeunesse et des
Sports socialiste possible
mais moi je reconnais ce que l'erreur
que nous avons faites par le passé alors
que vous persistez dans vos erreurs
aujourd'hui voilà où on en est vous êtes
de droite et reconnaissez on va revenir
quand même au sujet de droite
on va on va revenir
[Musique]